rock paper scissors shoot yes
yes
hey everyone i'm kelly and i'm mimo
welcome to another episode of lost in
translation last time katie jasmine and
mimo pulled a facet on me but this time
we're gonna pair katie and jasmine
together and we're in control if it's
your first time here we take our recipe
and put it through google translate we
go from english to kurdish to burmese to
swedish and many many more and then back
to english to get a hilariously
translated recipe let's give him the
recipe why not let's do it okay
i just got so scared three two what
a big bird it's like big bird
what yeah i don't like when they like
flap their wings that's all they can do
let's just talk about our strategy going
into it because there's two of us i feel
like we might mess each other up second
guessing i think so step one pour two
cups candy one cup drinking water two
teaspoons yellow and one teaspoon of
orange juice into the flour
or two cups candy do we think that's
sugar yes i think that is sugar one cup
drinking water assuming that's just
tap water they said this was hard and
this seems really easy so now my power i
start looking oh
what what i don't think they mean two
cups skittles do you yeah but we should
try it i think we need a bowl the bowl
is the flour the flour is the bowl like
a flower could be like you're just
eating candy come over here
i think if we figure out what orange
juice is it might help inform what sugar
we use one teaspoon orange extract is
one teaspoon of extract usually a lot oh
yeah cause one teaspoon of marmalade is
very little orange extract is probably
the weight
oh are we making a glaze no that's a lot
of water and that's a lot of sugar
they're laughing so hard i think it's
orange zest
no yeah and one cup of water is too much
for two cups of powdered sugar
i agree
it's gotta move on
i'm not gonna just you wait you better
be nice
[Laughter]
okay so two cups of sugar yes yeah you
know what it feels like right now it's
like we're in an escape room one cup
drinking water so regular water i think
it's fun because i'll get so scared up
here but katie makes me feel comfortable
what do you think yellow is so it could
be lemon or is it the juice of the
orange big bird is yellow though
i'm rolling out my lemons so that the
juices be flowing my husband always cuts
up the lemon and then it's like ah i
needed to get the zest
sorry we're just gonna eyeball it yeah
two teaspoons of yellow which we think
is lemon juice i think yeah when you
looked at the lemon i felt magic i was
like that's right into the flour could
be pour two yadda yadda ingredients into
a bowl
step two hey the party come and see me
give up the cup and the cup but not the
cup raised to one side for cooling i
feel like we're in a children's book i
think it's mix until incorporated divide
this into two but not all of it what if
give up the cup it's like reduced by a
cup
yeah
are you sure we're gonna mix this until
it reduces but not the cup and then
raise one so then remove from the heat
oh you know what i think may the party
come and see me was bring to a boil then
simmer or something oh i bet it was
something like that so we're gonna bring
this to a boil turn it down to a simmer
and then let it cool i think like right
now we're acing it
text if we are
so this is brought to a boil slightly
reduced and we are going to move it off
the heat let's move on to the next step
step three add the one cup italian
cheese quarter cup of sweet dripping
milk and one teaspoon of hot vinegar to
here you are beat to join
send it
beat to joy send it is italian cheese
ricotta there's stuff in the fridge
i did say ricotta but there's also
musk musk i always want to put on our
mars capone but it's
mimo says it's so nice it says italian
cream cheese it's italian okay we're
doing that buttercup sweet dripping milk
in my head i am either thinking milk or
condensed milk or heavy cream whipping
could be dripping
sweet ward smith i think that you are on
to something drippy milk whipping cream
a teaspoon of hot vinegar white vinegar
apple cider vinegar red wine
do we want red vinegar with this are we
making cheese curdles
i've never made cheese curdles
are there any that i said apple cider
vinegar
rice vinegar
i didn't say that you didn't
here you are two way another bowl okay
here let's just do a separate bowl first
okay and then we can always combine them
quarter cup whipping cream i'm like kind
of second guessing everything we did now
wow whatever let's just do it one cup
mascarpone i think vinegar comes with a
lot of science i'm down to use a hint
you're done to use a hen yes hint number
one don't think of it as spicy think of
it as temperature
our glue our glaze
yeah but first i'll take a teaspoon of
this mixture and add it to here
what do you think send it means set
aside set aside i like that next step
step number four over a large area add
two cups dust one teaspoon bread crumbs
half a teaspoon yeast powder one
tablespoon sugar and a half teaspoon the
ends okay so we're going to make a dough
on
right now in a large bowl add two cups
of flour
one teaspoon yeast way too many use
powders baking powder yeah baking powder
yes half teaspoon yeast i think it's
just baking i think it's not yeast i
think it's baking powder yes i think
yeast is a lot
yeast powder
damn but that one time i didn't put in
yeast i really
screwed myself over
okay how about we rock paper scissors if
you win we do baking soda if i win we do
yeast okay rock paper scissors shoot yes
yeast all right get your yeast do you
even see yeast no okay well all purpose
cake flour coconut flour
my gut is telling me it's regular flour
i'm always down for ap flour okay let's
just do ap
i think let's go yeast let's go yeast
and baking powder not soda what kind of
sugar do we think i think granulated
okay let's do granulated half a teaspoon
in the end and i'm going home goodbye
oh yes i think that's salt whatever
let's go if it's too salty oh well step
number five set the ball and two and a
half cups waves and dry the mousse
unfortunately the blend is well mixed
and does not wrinkle and cut two and a
half cups waves in the dry mousse so
that's i think is the dry mousse so
maybe we need is that weird to put that
in there and then like we mix until it's
smooth
i think that's correct
so we'll set the ball and two and a half
cups waves and dry it in the dry mousse
they're laughing
wrong
help us
step number six then warm awesome
electric finished
then warm awesome electric finish
honestly i don't know what else you
would do with those right now let rest
in a warm place
yeah electric finish bowl or preheat an
oven but they didn't give us a degree
let's put it in a bowl let's cover it up
let's wait till it electric finishes
step seven place one tablespoon in a pot
and make a three inch cassette if it
appears on the form delete it oh one
tablespoon of oil in a pot maybe i was
thinking that and then you make it three
inches like a oh my god like a cassette
player like a disc player boombox like
you know your old cassette player but
it's disc man
it does not
did you have a walkman
disc
cassette circles three inch circle yes
even one right right
once it comes to temperature
drop it in drop it in
so one tablespoon of oil is so little
wait i see waffle makers warm warm heat
waffle maker yeah
oh i love that
yeah
like you line it with oil
once it's hot yes this i think one
tablespoon oil makes sense okay delete
it if it browns remove if it burns or
moves oh yes yes three inches but how
thick yeah half an inch half an inch oh
it's so cute are we making shroom bubble
if so i'm so excited
look at these
cuties so we're just going to keep doing
this adding oil adding thin little
things of dough and then we'll move on
to we'll move on to the next step so
we've made what look like shrimp waffles
they are pretty cute now step eight says
send a disc add the corn and stir you
need to double the creams and roll the
sides is it set the disc in that
and then you need to roll it in that
corn starch there's literally corn on
that we're not gonna get trick
not today kelly i think we're supposed
to go in the dough let me see
we're like thinking double the cream we
have no cream we had cream but the grain
was in the dough
so now we're backtracking step five it
says set the ball in two and a half cup
waves now understanding that waste water
is water i think we can kind of make a
filling yes okay let's i'm gonna get a
bowl we can use ricotta cheese as a
filling okay that can make a sweet
filling yeah and then some sweet
dripping milk i mean we're just going
rogue now
yeah and then it was that hot vinegar
which we know is a syrup we've already
taken a little bit of a detour so to the
filling i'm gonna add two teaspoons of
orange marmalade so we have made our new
filling send to disk grab your disk add
the filling and spread you need to
double the creams and roll the sides and
press down yes until it comes out on the
side i like that yes
oh
what did you guys do
realized we messed up and we used the
mascarpone and into the dough but we
need the filling so we made new fillings
with ricotta step number nine the list
is based on the number and quality of
items maybe just repeat with the rest
use the rest based on how many waffles
you have we've done that let's move on
to the next step step 10 vegetable oil
is great at 350 degrees east
wait this is
okay
what we need to fry something at 350. we
need like a pot of oil that's 350
degrees
i think we should fry these now
and then after we take it out we can
glaze it with this but we not supposed
to use the waffle maker i think it's
bring
vegetable oil to 350. step 11 please
send pie in advance to the customer
please fry before serving oh yeah all
right you want to read the next one you
place the dishes on the table for about
three to five minutes or until all the
children are warm fry it for about three
to five minutes or until it's golden
brown i'm scared of oil
step thirteen
this is the best way to make love big
bird calm down what could that have
possibly
translated from this is best served warm
should i read the next line let's do it
no no
love maybe the syrup is love perhaps we
dip it in here or brush it over maybe
brush it over push it over all right so
what are we doing the best way to make
love is to
i would just brush it i've never seen
anything like this before we haven't
either
next step add a portion of salted bread
and pickled nuts pickled nuts here's
nuts pistachios pecans you have a hint
you've won hint left oh oh my god
activate hint what color are pickles
green
salted pistachios and we need to like
probably really
we have processed the pickled nuts i
think i'm just going to coat the top i
think that's nice step 15 do it again
with another cake done we did it big
bird step 16.
surprising whoa
i can't believe it's done let's plate it
and then bring in the real thing that
sounds good excited to see it i'm a
little terrified okay i'm closing my
eyes
okay okay three i did
do i open yes
oh
we made something that's so different
what is this called a thaif wow it's a
middle eastern pancake they do it in
different countries differently but this
is one version i cannot wait to try it i
can't wait to try it and it's so
different should we try ours first
wow
[Music]
so many feelings a part of me feels like
it doesn't actually match but when you
keep chewing the balance starts to come
together i love the texture it's like
crunchy but a little bit soft because of
the glaze
it's actually good you want to try this
one
a lot more flavor although i do like the
flavor of this one more i like the
texture of big bird this is very good
this was very fun i think two people did
make it harder and you guys made it very
hard this was so much fun kelly mimo you
y'all really got us back this time if
you guys have more recipe ideas please
message me at my instagram and don't put
it in the comments because jasmine will
definitely read it and we'll see you
guys next time bye bye
mm-hmm
i don't take these you take that one
[Laughter]
[Music]
you